WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT WE'RE HAPPY TO GET
OUR HEARING UNDERWAY.
WE WILL.
PASSED THE SERGEANTS TO CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND ONCE THEY
ARRIVE WE WILL ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. UNTIL THEN WE WILL.
ACT.
AS A COMMITTEE OF THE WHOLE AND.
THE COMMITTEE IS PLEASED TO SEE
THAT WE HAVE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
REYES WHO WAS HERE. AT THE
PRESENT.
A. B. TWO NINE SEVEN FOUR
WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES
WE'RE READY WHEN YOU ARE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR HANDS
MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY
NINE SEVENTY FOUR.
A BILL WHICH AIMS TO BETTER
POWER SMALL LOCAL BUSINESSES BY
ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE ADEQUATE
SUPPORT.
REPUBLIC CONTRACTING
OPPORTUNITIES.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S TO SUPPORT THE EFFORTS
OF EMPLOYERS TO ALIGN WITH
PUBLIC CONTRACTING NEEDS
THAT WILL SUPPORT LOCAL
WORKFORCE OPPORTUNITIES.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA SIGNED IN THE
WORKFORCE INNOVATION AND
OPPORTUNITY ACT WHICH SET NEW
STANDARDS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT NATIONWIDE.
THE ACT ALONG WITH STATE LAW.
REQUIRES OF BOARDS LEAD EFFORTS
TO ENGAGE WITH A DIVERSE RANGE
OF EMPLOYERS AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
ACHIEVE GOALS.
THESE GOALS INCLUDE PROMOTING
BUSINESS REPRESENTATION ON
BOARDS AND DEVELOPING EFFECTIVE
LINKAGES WITH EMPLOYERS TO
SUPPRT THE UTILIZATION OF THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT CENTERS.
SUPPORT ECONOMIC GROWTH.
LOCAL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD'S ARE TRULY WORKING AT THE
GROUND LEVEL. AND HAVE AN INNATE
UNDERSTANDING OF BUSINESS
AND WORKFORCE NEEDS.
DO TO THEIR LOCAL INTERACTION
WITH EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES.
REGULARLY STATE CONTRACTING CAN
BE COMPLICATED.
TO ACCESS SUPPORT FOR LOCAL
EMPLOYERS AS THEY SEEK TO FIND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WILL ALLOW
THEM TO GROW AND DRIVE LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEMANDS. THIS MAKES IT
IMPERATIVE THAT WE DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO INCLUDE ALL REGIONS OF
THE STATE AND EMPOWER THEM WITH
THE LOCAL ASSISTANCE TO THRIVE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION
FOR ENGAGING WITH MY OFFICE ON
THIS LEGISLATION. I LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH YOU
IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE THIS BILLS
WILL GOALS WHICH IS TO EMPOWER
LOCAL ECONOMIES.
AB TWO NINE SEVEN FOUR SUPPORTED
BY THE SAMBA DINO CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AS WELL AS SMALL
BUSINESSES CALIFORNIA.
HERE TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF SMALL
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA IS LORIE
KRAMER.
THE FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS ARE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS.
LAURIE KAMMERER SMALL BUSINESS
CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO SERVE ON ON THE TGS
SMALL BUSINESS ADVISORY COUNCIL
SO WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
PROCUREMENT WE TALK A LOT ABOUT
CONTRACTING OP OPPORTUNITIES.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS WE TO ALSO TALK
ABOUT CONTRACTING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR.
WOMEN I.
I HAD AND DABBED A SMALL
BUSINESSES AND THIS BILL IS VERY
IMPORTANT I'M I THINK IT PRETTY
MUCH AYE SHEDS AYE.
AYE AYE TRANSPARENCY. ON BETTER
COMMUNICATION.
SO THAT SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
AN IDEA OF THE CONTRACTS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM. THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
OTHERS WISHING TO ADD ON IN
SUPPORT.
POLLUTION AT ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE.
ARE YOU ADDING ON ITS SUPPORT.
GOT IT.
PRESUMABLY OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION.
GOT IT ALL RIGHT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SO DO YOU HAVE AN IN BETWEEN
POSITION.
I'LL QUE WE WELCOME AYE A
TWEENER POSITION.
TO THE MIND.
SORRY.
MISTER SHARON COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
.
ERIC FLOORS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT THE FORTY FIVE LOCAL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE REMAIN.
ON OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT TO
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT THE
DUPLICATIVE NATURE OF THE
REQUIREMENT ALREADY OVERLAPPING
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
REGULATIONS FOR. RFP PROCESS
THESE AND PROCUREMENT UNDER.
CONTRACTING THAT LOCAL BOARDS
ARE ALREADY REQUIRED TO DO FOR
ALL STATE FEDERAL AND LOCAL
GRANTS THAT WE HANDLE WE REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE.
THANK YOU OTHER.
IN BETWEEN POSITIONS ANY
OPPOSITION SAY NOT AGREE ABOUT
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU SUMMER
IS FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
WORKED A LOT WITH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT IN IN MY
JURISDICTION AS WELL. OF AS
TRYING TO INCREASE RATES OF
INCOME AND PROCESSES FOR
MINORITY WOMEN OWNED BUSINESSES
AND SO I THINK THERE'S
OPPORTUNITIES HERE. HOW TO
REALLY HELP SMALL BUSINESSES IN
A MEANINGFUL WAY?
AND OBVIOUSLY.
TO A WORK WITH THOSE WORKFORCE
A DEVELOPMENT BOARDS TO SHARE.
THAT THEY TRULY ARE PROVIDING
THE WORKFORCE NEEDS OF
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND AND
CERTAINLY THE REGION'S SO. I'M
AS SOON AS WE GET QUORUM I'M
MORE THAN HAPPY TO MAKE A
MOTION.
THAT WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
ESTABLISH.
ARE QUORUM SO LET'S GO AHEAD
AND DO THAT.
MEN SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THURMAN HERE
FLORA. GONZALEZ FLETCHER JONES
SAWYER HERE KALRA.
MCCARTY. MELENDEZ.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM.
.
THAT IS THE MOTION AND A SECOND
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION FROM
MEMBERS.
A SCENE NONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE TO LET THESE.
LOCAL BUSINESSES OF SMALL
BUSINESSES GETTING EQUAL CHANCE
WE AGREE IN THANK YOU SAYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO JOBS
COMMITTEE THURMAN AYE THURMOND
AYE FLORA GONZALEZ FLETCHER
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA.
KALRA I. MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
MELINDA'S BY THE.
YOU BILLS OUT COLLISIONS.
WE WILL CALL NEXT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY NINE FORTY SIX
.
LOCAL SERVER READY WHEN YOU ARE.
SO CLOSE I CAN MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY SIX
INCREASES THE STATURE
LIMITATIONS WERE FILING A WORKER
RETALIATION CLAIM FROM SIX
MONTHS TO THREE YEARS AND HAS
THE ABILITY TO SEEK ATTORNEY'S
FEES. FOR PREVAILING EMPLOYEES.
WORKPLACE RETALIATION OCCURS
AMPLY EMPLOYERS DISCHARGED
THREATEN TO DISCHARGE DEMOTE
SUSPEND OR SUBJECT EMPLOYEES TO
AN ADVERSE ACTION INCLUDING
THREATS OF DEPORTATION. FOR
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE LABOR CODE.
RETALIATION IS NOT ONLY
PERVASIVE BUT ALSO A GROWING
PROBLEM TO THE CURRENT POLITICAL
CLIMATE SURROUNDING IMMIGRATION.
IN FACT IN ITS TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN RETALIATION COMPLAINT
REPORT THE LEGISLATURE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER STATES OF THAT
THERE'S A TWENTY TWO PERCENT
INCREASE IN CASE ACCEPTED.
UP FROM TWENTY THREE UP FROM A
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN THE TWENTY
PERCENT JUMP.
THIS NUMBER DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
CASE THAT WE'RE NOT BOB FOR
VARIOUS REASONS LACK OF
AWARENESS. OF THE LENGTH THE
STASH LIMITATIONS DIFFICULT
DEFINING LEGAL REPRESENTATION.
BY THE PAPERWORK OR GATHERING
EVIDENCE ALL WITHIN A NARROW SIX
MONTH WINDOW.
TO THE CURRENT POLITICAL CLIMATE
IMMIGRANT WORKERS ARE OFTEN
AFRAID TO COME FORWARD WORKPLACE
RETALIATION CLAIMS FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS.
HOWEVER.
WHEN THEY DO ESPECIALLY GIVEN
ARE DUE TO LACK OF AWARENESS OF
THE SHORT STATURE LIMITATIONS.
OTHER CLAIMS NO LONGER ELIGIBLE
TO BE FILED.
FURTHERMORE NEARLY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED VIOLATIONS OF LABOR CODE
ELEVEN NO TWO POINT FIVE WERE
CITED IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN.
THIS VIOLATION IS NOT CURRENTLY
ALLOW FOR ATTORNEYS FEES FOR
PREVAILING EMPLOYEES.
THE BURDEN OF PAYING ATTORNEYS
FEES CAN BE A DETERRENT FOR
AGREE FOR OCCURS ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE LOW WAGE EVEN IF
THEY HAVE A STRONG CLAIM.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY SIX PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES OF A THREE YEAR PERIOD
OF TIME TO FILE RETALIATION
CLAIM ALIGNING WITH THE TIME TO
FILE A WAGE CLAIM TO LEMONADE.
ANY CONFUSION.
THE ATTORNEYS BE PROVISIONED
PROPELLING APPLY USE ENCOURAGES
AND PROTECTS WORKERS HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL ACTIONS FOR ABUSIVE
VIOLATIONS.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SPORTING
TESTIMONIES WAS SILVERTONE FROM
THE SAMPLER COUNTY WAGE THAT
COALITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF.
OF GUYS THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
WAGE THEFT COALITION THAT I
COORDINATE AND THAT SPONSORING
AB TWO NINE FOUR SIX.
I HAD TALKED TO ABOUT FIFTEEN
WORKERS ACT PASSED IF THEY WOULD
COME AND TESTIFY THEY'RE
PREDOMINANTLY UNDOCUMENTED AND
THEY'RE TERRIFIED SO I'M
SPEAKING ON THEIR BEHALF AND.
HOPEFULLY WILL TELL YOU SOME OF
THEIR STORIES I'M THE
SUPERVISING ATTORNEY OF THE
WORKERS RIGHTS CLINIC AT THE
CATHARINE AND GEORGE ALEXANDER
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER AT SANTA
CLARA UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW.
WE SERVE PREDOMINANTLY LOW WAGE
IMMIGRANT WORKERS WE ALSO HOLD
WE KEEP WEEKLY CLINICS. DREW
DURING ALL THREE LAW SCHOOL
SEMESTERS WE PARTNER WITH THE
VIETNAMESE BAR TO HOLD MONTHLY
KILL CLINICS IN THE FILIPINO
BAR.
TO HOLD QUARTERLY CLINICS WE'VE
ALSO INVESTIGATED RETALIATION
KIT CLAIMS ON BEHALF OF THE
LABOR COMMISSION.
IN THE PAST FIFTEEN YEARS THAT
I SUPERVISE THE CLINIC WE HAVE
REPEATEDLY SEEN WORKERS FIRED
FOR ASKING FOR UNPAID WAGES AND
WE'VE EVEN SEEN WORKERS
ASSAULTED WHEN THEY'VE ASKED FOR
WAGES. EMPLOYERS HAVE CONSTANTLY
MADE THREATS OF DEPORTATION ONE
WORKER SOUGHT UNPAID WAGES
TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM OF
EMPLOYERS WHO USE DEPORTATION
THREATS TO STEAL WAGES ARE
ENGAGE IN UNFAIR IMMIGRATION
REAL RETALIATION.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED A B. TWO
SIXTY THREE AND A. B. SIX SIXTY
SIX IN TWO THOUSAND AND
THIRTEEN.
ALTHOUGH THOSE WERE CRITICAL
FROM CHANGES
UP WE ARE STILL SEEING AN
INCREASE IN RETALIATION AND
IMMIGRATION RELATED THREATS.
ESPECIALLY IN THE CURRENT
CLIMATE AND.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA GAVE YOU
SOME STATISTICS ABOUT HOW THE
NUMBER HAD INCREASED TWENTY TWO
PERCENT.
AND ACTUALLY.
FROM TWO THOUSAND AND TWELVE TO
SIXTEEN THEY'VE GONE UP.
.
SEVENTY PERCENT IMMIGRATION
RELATED CASES HAVE INCREASED
MARKEDLY ACCORDING TO A PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT REQUEST BY A SOUTH
BAY NEWSPAPER.
SOUTH BAY MEANING SAN JOSE SOUTH
BAY IMMIGRATION RELATED
RETALIATION CLAIMS INCREASED
FROM SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN. TO TWENTY ARE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN AND NINETY
FIVE IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVENTEEN WE'VE OBSERVED AT OUR
WORKERS RIGHTS CLINIC THAT
EMPLOYERS ARE EMBOLDENED IN THIS
CURRENT POLITICAL CLIMATE. IN
SEVERAL OF OUR CASES THE
EMPLOYER LEFT THREATS OF
DEPORTATION ON WORKERS VOICE
MAIL.
WENT TO THE WORKERS HUSBANDS
WORKPLACE TO MAKE DEPORTATION
THREATS
AND THREATS OF LOSS OF HOUSING.
MADE REPEATED THREATS OVER THE
PHONE EVEN WHEN THIRD PARTY LIKE
THE HUSBAND WAS ON THE PHONE AND
IN ONE RECENT CASE THREATENED TO
HAVE THE CLIENT DEPORTED AND
KILLED. AND WE ENDED UP HAVING
TO GET A RESTRAINING ORDER IN
THAT CASE THE BIGGEST BARRIER TO
WORKERS IN FILING THESE CLAIMS
IS THE SHORT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS AND THE DIFFICULTY
IN FINDING REPRESENTATION. TO
HELP THEM NAVIGATE THE PROCESS.
MOST CLIENTS ARE UNAWARE THAT
THE STATUTE IS ONLY SIX MONTHS
WE'VE HAD SO MANY CLIENTS COME
WHERE IT'S BEEN SEVEN MONTHS
EIGHT MONTHS NINE MONTHS OR EVEN
A HERE. BECAUSE THEY ASSUME THAT
IT'S THREE YEARS JUST LIKE THE
WAGE CLAIMS
AND THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
FOR RETALIATION FOR A
DISCRIMINATE RETALIATION PACE IF
YOU'RE DISCRIMINATED AGAINST.
UNDER THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING ACT IS TO GO THROUGH A
IS AB ONE YEAR AND AT THE D. O.
WELL THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
IT'S TWO TO THREE YEARS AND IT'S
BEEN FRUSTRATING TO MEET WITH
THESE CLIENTS.
AFTER THE SIX MONTHS.
THOSE OPPOSING THE BILL STATE
OF THE WORKER HAS THE OPTION OF
GOING TO COURT HOWEVER MOST
LAWYERS CAN'T ECONOMICALLY
AFFORD TO TAKE CASES TO COURT IF
THE PLAINTIFF IS A LOW WAGE
WORKER WITH A SMALL AMOUNT OF
BACK PAY. AND WE HAVE HAD VERY
LITTLE SUCCESS IN REFERRING
WORKERS TO PRIVATE ATTORNEYS
ANOTHER BARRIER IS A LACK OF
INCENTIVE FOR THE PRIVATE PARTY
TAKE CASES BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ATTORNEY FEE PROVISION. THERE'S
AN ATTORNEY FEE PROVISION FOR
PREVAILING PET PLAINTIFFS IN
WAGE IN OUR OUR CASES BUT NOT IN
RETALIATION CASES SO IN OTHER
WORDS IF YOUR EMPLOYER DOESN'T
PAY YOU. YOU YOU DO YOU CAN GO
TO COURT AND GET ATTORNEY'S FEES
BUT IF YOU COMPLAIN THAT YOU'RE
NOT GETTING PAID AND YOU'RE
FIRED. THERE'S NO ATTORNEYS FEES
ALSO OTHER WHISTLEBLOWER
STATUTES AND RETALIATION STATUES
HAVE ATTORNEY FEES FOR
PREVAILING WAGES FOR EXAMPLE THE
CALIFORNIA WHISTLEBLOWER ACT.
HAS IT AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING RETALIATION
PROVISIONS THEY ALSO HAVE
ATTORNEYS FEES.
AND THIS BILL WILL NOT ONLY HELP
WORKERS FAILING FACING THREATS
OF DEPORTATION BUT IT'LL ALSO
HOPE WORKERS WHO ARE RETALIATED
AGAINST BECAUSE THEY COMPLAINED
ABOUT EQUAL PAY. CRITICAL HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROBLEMS OR SICK PAY
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WORKERS FILE
THESE CASES AND THE SHORT
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS AND LACK
OF ATTORNEYS FEES ARE BARRIERS
TO ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
THANK YOU A DID YOU HAVE
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
I'VE SEEN THAT ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO ADD ON SUPPORT TO THIS
BILL.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HEY JULIA PARISH WITH LEGALLY
THAT WORK WHERE STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT THAT REPRESENTS LOW
WAGE WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO COLLECT A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY WITH WORK
SAFE FOR PART OF THE LEGAL AID
NETWORK WE ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
WORKERS WITH RESPECT TO HEALTH
AND SAFETY AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU.
MARY CRAZE OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ENOUGH FLOORS WITH
THE MAINTENANCE COOPERATION
TRUST FUND AND WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE QUEUE.
BRIAN HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION ON IT BUT
IB RECOMMEND TO SUPPORT.
Q. ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO ADD ON
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
COULD WE MAKE A SPACE HERE BUT
MAKE A SPACE FOR YOU AND THE
TABLE.
YEAH AYE GOOD AFTERNOON OR
CURTIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY WE
ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION. TO
TWENTY NINE FORTY SIX AM
SOMETHING THAT WAS MENTIONED BUT
JUST TO CLARIFY PROVE ME RIGHT
NOW THROUGH THE JEALOUSY THAT
JEALOUSY IS NOT ADMINISTRATIVE
REMEDY THAN INDIVIDUAL NEEDS TO
GO THROUGH IN ORDER TO GET CIVIL
COR IT'S KIND OF A CHOOSE YOUR
OWN ADVENTURE THEY CAN I'LL FOR.
EITHER FILE WITH THE DLC OR THEY
CAN FILE IN CIVIL COURT IN CIVIL
COURT YOU DO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACHIEVE M.
ATTORNEY'S FEES AND IT'S A MORE
LITIGIOUS PROCESS OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE CHOOSE TO GO THROUGH THE
JEALOUSY PROCESS BECAUSE THEY'RE
LOOKING JUST FOR. FOR UNPAID
WAGES OR THESE ISSUES AND SO
THEY DON'T WANT TO UTILIZE THE
CIVIL LITIGATION PROCESS BECAUSE
OF THOSE REASONS AND HOWEVER
THERE IS NO MAGISTRATE OF REMEDY
FOR THEM TO FILE WITH THE
JEALOUSY FIRST THEY CAN GO AHEAD
AND GO AUTOMATICALLY TO CIVIL
COURT IF THAT'S THE OPPORTUNITY.
THEY CHOOSE AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY STAND ARE ANY OPPOSITION TO
THE EXTENSION OF STEP TWO
LIMITATIONS AT THE TOP THIS TIME
OUR CONCERN IS THE ATTORNEY'S
FEES THE DLC PROCESS. IS A.
PROCESS ACTUALLY WALKS THE I'VE
I'VE BEEN THROUGH IT WALKS THE
INDIVIDUAL THROUGH THE PROCESS
THE REPRESENTATIVE OFTENTIMES
WILL GIVE THEM THEIR OF THE FAKE
GIVE LEGAL ADVICE ASSIST THEM
WITH.
NEGOTIATING SETTLEMENTS AND ALL
OF THOSE ISSUES WHERE AN
ATTORNEY NORMALLY COULD HELP OUT
IN THOSE SITUATIONS THE AND
DILISIO REPRESENTATIVE REALLY
DOES WALK THEM THROUGH IT THE
EMPLOYER DOES NOT HAVE CONTACT
WITH THE INDIVIDUAL ON THESE
CONFERENCE CALLS. AND THE
INDIVIDUAL MEETS WITH THE
JEALOUSY REPRESENTATIVE AND THEN
THE INDIVIDUAL MEETS WITH THE
EMPLOYER AND THEN THE.
REPRESENTATIVE DICK DISCUSSES
IT WITH THEM AND AND SO I JUST
WANTED TO LET YOU ALL KNOW THAT
IT IS A A SEPARATE PROCESS I'M
HAS THEIR YOU KNOW THESE WALKED
THROUGH THE THE ENTIRE PROCESS.
AND AND SO THIS WOULD MAKE AT
THE DLC PROCESS THAT HAS BEEN A
CALIFORNIA AMBULANCE
ASSOCIATION ON THIS MEASURE IN.
TWO QUICK THINGS ONE IS.
THE EARLIER SUPPORT WITNESS THE.
A WE DON'T IN ANY WAY CONDONE
RETALIATION AND CERTAINLY THE
THREATS OF DEPORTATION ARE ARE
PRETTY OUTRAGEOUS SO I DON'T
WANT OUR OPPOSITION TO. BE
PERCEIVED IN ANYWAY AS CONDONING
THAT SORT OF ACTIVITY. ALSO THE.
AUTHOR AND STAFF AND HIS STAFF
HAVE BEEN VERY GENEROUS WITH
THEIR TIME ON THIS MEASURE AS
MISS CURTIS INDICATED WE DON'T
HAVE AN ISSUE WITH THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS PROVISION.
WE THINK THAT THE DEAL S. C.
PROCESSES OF IT.
VERY EMPLOYER FRIENDLY.
IN WITH THE AWARD OF ATTORNEY'S
FEES IT'LL TURN IT INTO A MUCH
MORE ADVERSARIAL PROCESS.
IN LOOKING AT SUBDIVISION J.
THAT THE BILL.
THERE'S NO DEFINITION OF WHAT
IS A SUCCESSFUL ACTION.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT DOES THAT
MEAN A RECOVERY OF SIMPLY ONE
DOLLAR.
ALSO I WOULD NOTE THAT IT'S A
ONE SIDED ATTORNEY'S FEES IT'S
NOT FOR BOTH SIDES WHOEVER MAY
PREVAIL. AND IS YOUR ANALYSIS
NOTES ON PAGE TWO LAST YEAR. A
SENATOR HERTZBERG AUTHORED
LEGISLATION THAT THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY DID OPPOSE BUT IT
GRANTED A FERRET AMOUNT OF
ADDITIONAL POWERS TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
AS WELL AS TO PRIVATE
INDIVIDUALS TO WORKERS AND WE
THINK THAT THAT BILL LOT OF.
BE ALLOWED TO TAKE A FACT I
WOULD ALSO NOTE A SINCE THE A
SUPPORT WITNESS WAS FROM. A WAGE
THEFT AS WELL THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY NOT ONLY WORKED ON AB
TWO SIXTY THREE THAT WAS CITED
BUT. TWO YEARS AGO.
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH THE PRO
TEM TO SUPPORT S. B. FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT THAT GRANTED EXTENSIVE.
ADDITIONAL POWERS TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO DEAL WITH WAGE
THEFT I AND WE WOULD PREFER
THOSE TYPES OF POWERS TO BE IN
THE HANDS OF THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER. WE THINK AGAIN
THAT THE ATTORNEYS FEES
PROVISION WILL INCENTIVIZE.
UNNECESSARY LITIGATION AND TURN
THAT DEAL AS HE PROCESS INTO
MORE OF AN ADVERSARIAL ACTIVITY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MIKE
BELOW APPEARING TODAY FOR THE
CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THIS QUESTION OF WHAT
A PREVAILING THE USE OF THE
REALLY GOOD FOOD PRETTY.
IT'S AN OPPOSITE.
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY HIM SOME OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION AQ.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW ON
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION ALSO
OPPOSED.
WHAT ELSE ADDING ON IN
OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE LIKE TRYING TO THE
MEMBERS SHOWS THAT? THEY THE
ROBO AGREE
OF THAT THERE IS MORE TIME YOU
DO APPROPRIATELY RECONCILE THESE
CASES AND I CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THEM. UP POETICALLY THAT I AS IT
APPLIES THE ATTORNEY'S FEES
REPAIR MEMBER.
THAT.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT PREVAILING
PARTY WHAT HAVE YOU BUT THERE
ISN'T A BALANCE OF POWER WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT.
THE PARTIES THAT ARE WELL LIKE
MOVES OVER TO UP TO
THE RIGHT AT ME THAT WORKS FOR
NON PROFITS THAT WORKS WITH
THAT.
IRV OPEN THEM ALL LAW CENTER
AND OTHER.
PRO BONO TYPE EFFORTS BE ABLE
TO HIRE ANOTHER STAFF ATTORNEY
CIVIC REPRESENT MORE WORKERS
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
FATTY THE COFFERS OF OF LAWYERS
ARE REALLY TALK ABOUT THE
ABILITY. FOR THOSE THAT DON'T
HAVE A VOICE TO HAVE A VOICE AND
BASS WITH HIS ATTORNEY FEES
WOULD ALLOW FOR AGAIN ARE ONLY
SITUATIONS WHERE THE. A DUMP
EMPLOYER A ISD FAULT SO WITH
THAT RESPECT THE ASPIRIN YOU THE
TWO.
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER PRESENT.
.
THREE BILLS.
ONLY THREE ONLY THREE.
I ORDERED.
WE DO NOT.
LET'S START WITH HIM CASE.
EACH TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ONE AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY
ONE ALLOWS EMPLOYEES TO USE UP
TO FIVE PAID SICK DAYS A YEAR
WITHOUT FACING WAGE LOSS OR
RETALIATION. AS YOU KNOW FOUR
YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA SET A
NATIONAL STANDARD BY PROVIDING
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION WORKERS
WITH THE LONG OVERDUE PROTECTION
OF THREE PAID SICK DAYS. WE
BECAME THE FIRST.
STATE IN THE NATION TO ENSURE
THAT EVERY PRIVATE SECTOR WORKER
WAS ABLE TO EARN PAID SICK DAYS.
SINCE THEN. OTHER STATES IN
MAJOR CITIES IN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING OAKLAND BERKELEY LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO HAVE PASSED
MORE EXPANSIVE LAWS GRANTING
WORKERS WITH AT LEAST FIVE DAYS
OF SICK LEAVE IF NOT MORE.
THIS YEAR IN PARTICULAR FLEA
RELATED HOSPITALIZATION
MORTALITY RATES HAVE BEEN
UNPRECEDENTED THE CENTER FOR
DISEASE CONTROL AND PREVENTION
REPORTS OF PEOPLE WHO FELL ILL
WITH THE FLU NEEDED AT LEAST A
WEEK TO RECOVER.
FOR WORKING FAMILIES STRUGGLING
TO MAKE ENDS MEET THE LACK OF
SUFFICIENT PAID SICK DAYS COULD
HAVE COST THEM ON AVERAGE THEIR
ENTIRE MONTHLY BUDGET FOR
GROCERIES.
IT'S TIME THAT WE STRENGTH THAN
WHAT WE'VE ALREADY CREATED AND
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE CAN TAKE THE
ADEQUATE NUMBER OF SICK DAYS A
YEAR. AND WE THINK IT'S TIME
AFTER SEEING THE OVERWHELMING
SUCCESS OF THREE DAYS TO EXPAND
THAT TO FIVE LIKE SO MANY OF OUR
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE ALREADY
DONE.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE A FEW
TESTIMONIES FROM.
TWO WITNESSES.
WHO'S IN CHARGE NOW.
I.
WE. YEAH I'M SORRY I'M TALKING
TO TONY AND HE'S GONE.
HEY. MY NAME IS HOLLY DEUS I AM
I'M LEADER FOR THE SACRAMENTO
PAY FOR FIFTEEN AND UNION
RIGHTS.
AND I AM ALSO A FAST FOOD WORKER
OF THEM AND THEY HAVE A CHILD
WHO IS TWO YEARS OLD.
M..
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK ASSEMBLY
WOMAN GONZALEZ.
FORUM GETTING THE THREE BASIC
PAY FOR US.
I'VE HAD TO WORK WITH STREP
THROAT BRONCHITIS FOOD POISONING
PNEUMONIA. M. MY SON WAS REALLY
SICK AS A BABY.
AND THERE WERE DAYS THAT HE WAS
CRYING IN PAIN AND INSTEAD OF
BEING THE MOTHER THAT I SHOULD
HAVE BEEN I HAVE TO GO TO WORK
BECAUSE IF I MISS ONE DAY A
WORK.
TO BE A MOTHER THAT'S LATE.
A LOT OF MONEY.
THAT WERE MISSING SO HURRY BEGIN
EMOTIONAL SORRY.
AND IT'S REALLY HARD WHEN.
YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
WORKING AND BEING A MOTHER I
GREW UP WITHOUT A MOTHER AND I
WILL NOT ALLOW MY CHILD TO MISS
OUT.
AND SO I KNOW THE STRUGGLES.
THE.
MY FATHER WENT THROUGH YOU KNOW.
AND I'M REALLY HOPING THAT. WE
CAN GET THE EMBRACE TO FIVE DAYS
BECAUSE.
THE FLU SEASON THIS YEAR KILLED
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THEY WERE HAVING TO GO
TO WORK IF THEY WERE ABLE TO GET
PAID TO TAKE TIME OFF WORK THEY
WOULD GET THE ADEQUATE MEDICAL
ATTENTION THAT THEY WOULD NEED
AND THEY WOULD STILL BE HERE
WITH US TODAY. THINK.
MY NAME IS DONNA LEVITT. BEFORE
RETIRING TO YEARS AGO I HEADED
THE SAN FRANCISCO OFFICE OF
LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT.
WHICH ENFORCES THE COUNTRY'S
FIRST PAID SICK LEAVE ORDINANCE.
I'M TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ONE BECAUSE I
BELIEVE BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE.
THAT AN INCREASE OF THE MINIMUM
A CRUEL CAP FROM THREE TO FIVE
DAYS IS A MODEST AND MUCH NEEDED
IMPROVEMENT TO THE CALIFORNIA
LAW.
A MINIMUM OF CRUEL CAP OF FORTY
HOURS IS NOW STANDARD FOR CITY
AND STATE LAWS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN THE SAN FRANCISCO
LAW HAS PROVIDED FOR IN A CRUEL
CAP OF SEVENTY TWO HOURS FOR
EMPLOYERS WITH TEN OR MORE
EMPLOYEES. AND FORTY HOURS FOR
SMALLER BUSINESSES.
ALTHOUGH EACH STATE LAW IS
DIFFERENT PAID SICK LEAVE LAWS
IN CONNECTICUT MASSACHUSETTS
OREGON ARIZONA AND MARYLAND ALL
HAVE PROVISIONS FOR MINIMUM CAPS
OF FORTY HOURS PER YEAR.
LAWS IMPLEMENTED THIS YEAR IN
VERMONT AND RHODE ISLAND WILL
PHASE UP TO FORTY HOURS IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEENIN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY RESPECTIVELY.
AND THE STATE OF WASHINGTON DOES
NOT ALLOW EMPLOYERS TO CAP
APPROVALS AT ALL.
CALIFORNIA'S LAW IS A LIFE
CHANGER FOR LOW INCOME EMPLOYEES
BUT IN TOO MANY SITUATIONS
WORKERS STILL CAN'T AFFORD TO
STAY HOME WHEN THEY ARE SICK OR
NEED TO CARE FOR A SICK FAMILY
MEMBER.
PLEASE SUPPORT AB TWENTY EIGHT
FORTY ONE TO AMEND THE LAW TO
BETTER NEED MEET THE NEEDS OF
WORKING FAMILIES.
AS YOU KNOW PAID SICK LEAVE IS
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY.
IT'S GOOD FOR EMPLOYEES FOR
EMPLOYERS AND FOR PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
DEAN SMITH CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP AND MYSTIC VIOLENCE
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY CA DOCTOR OFF
ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MICHELLE POCKET WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
ANGELIQUE WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MICHAEL MCLAUGHLIN AND EIGHTY
RPG VOLUNTEER AND WITH THE
CAPITAL RESPONSE TEAM.
I'M HERE IN BEHALF OF OUR THREE
POINT THREE MILLION.
MEMBERS IN CALIFORNIA.
A P. STANCE.
STRONGER JUST USE A. OF NAME IS
A PORTMANTEAU THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
JULIA PARISH LEGAL IT WORK IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA WORKING
FAMILIES COALITIONS FOR.
HELLO CRISTINA BOSS HAMILTON
WITH YOU W. AFFECTS ME
REPRESENTING I JUST US WORKERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHERYL'S THEM ON BEHALF OF FIONA
MOB VICE CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION
PART OF AB TWENTY FORTY ONE I
THINK YOU TO REMEMBER BRING THIS
FOR.
JESSICA BARTOLO WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
BIRTH SILVER TOBE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHICH THAT'S COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
SHANE GUSMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND UNITE HERE IN
SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WHENEVER I DON'T SEE HOW YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
TAYLOR JACKSON AT THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
TIM RYAN WITH UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE OUTSIDE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
.
SO MORNING OR AFTERNOON I THINK
NOW I'LL LARA CURTIS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND AYE OBVIOUSLY WE
ARE SYMPATHETIC TO THE WITNESSES
THAT AND DISCUSS THEIR ISSUES
TODAY SO WE AND DO APPRECIATE
THEM COMING TO THESE. HEARINGS
BUT.
AT THIS POINT WE ARE ON OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE WE FEEL
THAT IT IS TOO AND TO MUCH TOO
SOON THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES
WITH THE PAID SICK LEAVE.
ORDINANCE AS IT STANDS THAT
HAVEN'T BEEN ADDRESSED.
FOR EXAMPLE THEIR NOTICE AND
VERIFICATION REQUIREMENTS AND
OTHER LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT ARE
INCLUDED IN THIS FOR EXAMPLE SAN
DIEGO ALLOWS YOU TO VERIFY SICK
LEAVE AFTER THREE DAYS IS TAKEN.
WHILE THAT AND CITY ALLOWS FOR
FIVE DAYS OF SICK LEAVE IF THREE
DAYS OF TAKEN THE EMPLOYER CAN
THEN VERIFY WHETHER OR NOT I'M
WITH IT YOU WITH SOME SORT
VERIFICATION FROM THE EMPLOYEE.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ADDRESS THAT
ADDITIONALLY AND THERE ARE IN
THE BILL IT SAYS THAT YOU ARE UP
TO THREE DAYS OR TWENTY FOUR
HOURS WHILE THE FAQS ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING. HAS STATED THAT IT IS
WHATEVER IS IN BETTER INTEREST
OF THE EMPLOYEE THAT'S NOT
ACTUALLY IN THE STATUE AND SO WE
WOULD LIKE THOSE ISSUES.
DISCUSSED AND THEN OTHER
DOCUMENTATION REQUIREMENTS RATE
OF PAY THINGS LIKE THAT THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DISCUSSED IN THE
CURRENT STATUTE THAT NEEDS IN
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE AND AND.
THEM ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY RECOGNIZED AS BY THE
NATIONAL CONFERENCE OF STATE
LEGISLATORS ONE MOST FAMILY
FRIENDLY STATES AND AND THERE
ARE ADDITIONAL PROGRAMS THAT
ALLOW FOR AND TIME OFF SUCH AS A
FAMILY SIT FRONT ALTHOUGH IS
EITHER. AND AREAS SO THAT'S OUR
IF WE ARE TO OPPOSITION AS OF
NOW AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
TODAY THANK YOU.
SIR TURN MEMBERS MIGHT BELOW
APPEARING FOR THE.
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAW
COUNCIL AND THE CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA I.
WANT TO SAY THAT I DISCUSSED
THIS ISSUE IN DEPTH WITH MS
GONZALEZ FLETCHER WHEN THE FIRST
ATOM. OF LAW WAS ENACTED AND SHE
WAS REMARKABLY. OPEN CALIFORNIA
LAW YESTERDAY I GOT
A CALL FROM A HAIR SALON OWNER
WHO'S TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT
HE WILL?
?
STYLISTS
IF A BASED ON COMMISSION PAY OR
PEACE THREE RATE PAY. UP UNDER
THE SAN FRANCISCO ORDINANCE AND
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA LAW AND HOW
THEY'RE DIFFERENT AND HOW THEY
INTER RELATE AND IT IS MIND
NUMBINGLY COMPLICATED. AND
HEAVEN HELP THE PERSON WHO
HASTERT.
DO BUSINESS IN MULTIPLE CITIES
WITH DIFFERENT ORDINANCES AND
COMPLY WITH CALIFORNIA LAW SO WE
WOULD ARGUE THAT AT AT LEAST
IT'S TIME TO HAVE A UNIFORM
STANDARD IN CALIFORNIA THAT
BUSINESSES CAN RELY ON. AND MANY
OF OUR BUSINESSES DO OPERATE IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS THAT
HAVE.
MULTIPLE ORDINANCES AND I'M
HERE TO TELL YOU THEY'RE PULLING
THEIR HAIR OUT THIS IS A VERY
VERY COMPLICATED.
THING AND WE'D LIKE A SIMPLE
RULE THAT PEOPLE COULD
UNDERSTAND AND I REPRESENT BIG
EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE ARMIES OF
LAWYERS TO DO IT.
PITY THE POOR SMALL BUSINESS WHO
HAVE TO FIGURE IT OUT ON THEIR
OWN OR COUNT ON A ON A PAYROLL
COMPANY TO DO IT FOR THEM. SO
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT IN
THE WORLD MOST OF OUR COMPANIES
PROVIDE MORE THAN THAT THREE
DAYS BUT SOMETHING OUGHT TO BE
DONE ABOUT UNIFORMITY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION.
FAITH BRING BORDERS ON BEHALF OF
THE FAMILY BUSINESS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS BUT DOESN'T MISTER
BELOW THANK YOU.
TRUE TO HIS OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF FOOD PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION.
KATIE HANSON CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
MATTHEW ON WESTERN GROWERS ALSO
OPPOSE.
ANY MERKLEY CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU POST.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
PROJECT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
TO THE AUTHOR WOULD WOULD YOU
LIKE TO ADDRESS THE COMMENTARY.
ABOUT HOW.
YOU KNOW CONSISTENCY ACROSS
JURISDICTIONS IN WHAT EIGHT
EMPLOYERS CAN REASONABLY EXPECT
TO KNOW WHAT THEIR OBLIGATIONS
ARE.
WELL I THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE
ANYTHING AS FAR AS CONSISTENCY
RIGHT WHEN AND I DO RECOGNIZE
AND APPRECIATE THAT IF YOU ARE
RUNNING A BUSINESS IN MULTIPLE
CITIES WITH DIFFERENT. AT
PAPERWORK REQUIREMENTS.
.
ACCRUAL RATES THAT IT IS
DIFFICULT
IT'S DIFFICULT TODAY IT WOULD
REMAIN DIFFICULT IF EXTENDED TO
FIVE DAYS FROM THE STATE.
I THINK IT IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO ACCEPT THAT FIVE
DAYS IS A BETTER STANDARD TO
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE ASKING FIVE
DAYS IN THE COME IN AND SEE IF
WE CAN TALK ABOUT STREAMLINING
BETWEEN THE STATE. AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS SOME OF.
SOME OF THOSE INCONSISTENCIES
WE HAVEN'T HAD WE'VE HAD SOME
WE'VE HAD ONE CLEAN UP BILL
ALREADY.
BUT I WOULD LOVE A TO INVITE
THEM INTO THAT DISCUSSION
KNOWING THAT WHAT THIS BILL DOES
TODAY IS JUST EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF DAYS.
AVAILABLE TO WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA A RIGHT THAT RT EXIST
UNDER LAW FOR THREE DAYS I'M
SEMI OF OUR JURISDICTIONS IN
AND.
PROBABLY MAJORITY OF WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA FALL UNDER A HIGHER
STANDARD ARE READY AND BUT IT
DOES PROVIDE THEM A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY COME IN AND SAY
EXACTLY.
WHAT CHANGES AT AND I WANNA BE
REALLY CLEAR NOT CHANGES IN
PREEMPTING LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE?
EVEN MORE DAYS LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO WE HAVE NO INTEREST
IN.
.
TELLING A LOCAL JURISDICTION
THAT THEY PROVIDE TOO MANY DAYS
WE THINK THAT'S UP TO THOSE
LOCAL AREAS TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND
THIS EVEN FURTHER. BUT WE'D BE
HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH BUSINESS
AND TO A. LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
FIND OUT IF WE CAN'T STREAMLINED
SOME OF.
THAT WHAT THEY ARE SEEN AS
INCONSISTENCIES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WILLINGNESS
TO WORK WITH THOSE BUSINESS
GROUPS THANK YOU SIDE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEN THEM THERE IS A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PROBLEMS.
NOW I I I I THINK I I I THINK MR
PHILIP PACK FOR HIS COMMENTS
BECAUSE I WAS VERY HONEST WHEN
WE GET THREE DAYS AND WE DID IT
FOR A REASON I WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS.
WE BECAME THE FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION TO NOT LEAVE ANYONE
BEHIND ON WE EVENTUALLY A IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WE EVENTUALLY
CAUGHT UP OUR PUBLIC SECTOR
EMPLOYEES ARE IHS THAT'S WORKERS
WITH.
WITH ARROW WE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASE WEEK WE PUT OUR SICK
DAYS INTO THAT SO WE ARE THE
ONLY STATE THAT DIDN'T EXEMPT
ANY EMPLOYEES AND HAVE A A.
CLEAR STANDARD ACROSS THE BOARD
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE IS TO RAISE THAT UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT WE ARE CLEAR THAT WE
WANTED TO DO THAT WE STARTED
WITH THREE SO THAT WE COULD GET.
A MINIMUM STANDARD AND WE KNEW
WHERE WE WERE VERY HONEST WITH
PEOPLE THAT WE ARE COMING BACK
IT'S A GREAT TIME TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT WHAT WE NEED
CLARIFIED IT IT'S IT'S A
OPPORTUNITY FOR BUSINESS TO COME
IN AND BE PART OF THE SOLUTION
AND NOT JUST FIGHT. I WANNA.
ALSO THEY THEY DIDN'T BRING UP
SOME VERY EXCITED TO HEAR THAT
IT'S NOT BEING CALLED A JOB
KILLER. BE ACCUSED OF THAT
BECAUSE AFTER WHAT'S CALLED A
JOB KILLER AFTER THREE DAYS
WE'VE SHOWN THAT ACTUAL
PRODUCTIVITY. AND ON THE JOB
NUMBERS HAVE GONE UP IN
CALIFORNIA FOR A PASTOR ARE
MANDATORY SICKLY POLICIES AND
SO.
I THINK THAT THIS IS A JOB
CREATOR BILL AND IT WILL
CONTINUE TO INCREASE
PRODUCTIVITY OF OUR WORKERS SO
I'M GRATEFUL THAT WE HAVE ON
TRANSITION TO ANY DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU THIS BILL DOES HAVE AN
AYE RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THURMOND AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO GONZALEZ FLETCHER I
HAVE GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
KALRA. KALRA I. MCCARTY
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO.
THAT BILL IS OUT ARE YOU READY
FOR THIS AT YOUR NEXT BILL FOR.
I WILL AND.
TWO A. B. TWO FOUR NINE SIX
PRESUMPTION OF EMPLOYMENT TWO
FOUR NINE SIX.
WE'RE READY WHEN YOU ARE
THINKING CALIFORNIA TRACKS A
HIGH RATE OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
DUE TO THE STRONG ECONOMY LARGE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES IN OUR
PROXIMITY TO U. S. MEXICO
BORDER.
TWENTY TWELVE STUDY CONDUCTED BY
SENIOR STATE UNIVERSITY FOUND
THAT RATES OF LABOR TRAFFICKING
OF IMMIGRANT WORKERS IN THE
PROPERTY SERVICE INDUSTRY WERE
AMONG THE HIGHEST OF ANY
INDUSTRY.
DESPITE EFFORTS TO CURTAIL ABUSE
AGAINST PROPERTY SERVICE WORKERS
ESPECIALLY JANITORS IT'S WELL
DOCUMENTED NUMEROUS UNSCRUPULOUS
BUSINESS PREY ON MIGRANT WORKERS
FOR THIS INDUSTRY BY OFFERING
THEM LONG HOURS WITH LITTLE TO
NO PAY.
THESE JANITORS MANY OF WHOM ARE
TRAFFICKED TO THIS COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY ARE ALSO COURSE INTO
INDENTURED LABOR ENTRAPPED IN
JOBS WHICH EMPLOYERS HAVE
COMPLETE CONTROL OVER MOST
ASPECTS OF THEIR LIFE.
LABOR TRAFFICKERS LURE WORKERS
BY MAKING FALSE PROMISES
OFFERING HIGH PAY EDUCATION
TRAVEL OPPORTUNITIES AND ONCE
THE WORKER GREECE A JOB THERE
INSTEAD AGREED WITH LIES AND
HERBAL TREATMENT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN SEEN IS A MESS
CLASSIFICATION OF THESE WORKERS
THIS MESS CLASSIFICATION
PREVENTS EMPLOYERS FROM BEING
HELD RESPONSIBLE TO PAY OVERTIME
WORKERS COMPENSATION OR NUMBER
OF OTHER BENEFITS.
IN NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN THE
LABOR CODE SECTION TWO SEVEN
FIVE ZERO POINT FIVE WASN'T
ACTED TO ENSURE THE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WERE NOT MISS.
CLASSIFIED AS INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS
OVER EIGHTY YEARS LATER A. B.
TWO FOUR NINE SIX WOULD PROVIDE
JANITORS AND ALL PROPERTY
SERVICE WORKERS THOSE SAME
PROTECTIONS A PRESUMPTION OF
BEING EMPLOYEES. WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY IS.
.
DAN REYES MEN.
FROM THE THE DEPUTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
AND NOW FLOOR IS FROM THE
MAINTENANCE CORPORATION TRUST
ON.
TWO OF THE FIRST WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS.
I'M DAN REISMAN I MAY DIP YOU
JUST RETURNING WITH ALAMEDA
COUNTY I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY NANCY O'MALLEY WHO IS THE
SPONSOR THIS BILL.
.
I HAVE MY OWN EXPERIENCE I IN
THE OFFICE PROSECUTING WORKER'S
COMP FRAUD AND LABOR ABUSES
BOB FROM A CRIMINAL PERSPECTIVE
AND AND WHAT. I KNOW AND I THINK
EVERY WORKERS COMP.
FRAUD PROSECUTOR KNOWS IS THAT
IT OF THE BIG TOOL THAT'S USED
IN INVESTIGATIONS OF WORKPLACE
ABUSES.
ESPECIALLY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IS THE EXISTING REGIME
OF THE PRESUMPTION THAT AN
UNLICENSED.
SUBCONTRACTORS CONSIDERED AN
EMPLOYEE.
AND WE WE USE IN THAT IN THAT.
CONTEXT WE USE THAT PRESUMPTION
TO CREATE WORKERS COMP FRAUD
PROSECUTIONS AND AND PAYROLL TAX
FRAUD PROSECUTIONS.
.
THE STUDY IN TWENTY TWELVE FROM
SAN DIEGO FOUND THAT.
THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY.
CRIED EVEN MORE INCIDENTS MORE
HIGHER RATES OF OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND LABOR
EXPLOITATION THEN DID THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IT'S CLOSE
BUT IT HAS EVEN MORE AND. AND IT
MAKES SENSE FROM WHAT WE KNOW
ABOUT LABOR TRAFFICKING AND
LABOR EXPLOITATION THAT THAT
DARKNESS LACK OF HUMAN CONTACT
LACK OF REGULATION IS WHAT.
IS WHAT ENCOURAGES THE KINDS OF
ABUSES THAT WE SEE IN THOSE
INDUSTRIES WE HAVE THIS
PRESUMPTION IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IT WORKS VERY WELL TO
BRING ATTENTION. NOT JUST FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS IN THE CSL BE.
AS THAT NINETEEN SEVENTY AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT BILL.
BRINGS IN THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF THE
PRESUMPTION WE ADD ON ATTENTION
FROM.
FEED.
INSURANCE FRAUD DIVISION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE THE.
PAYROLL TAX FRAUD DIVISION OF
THE EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT AND ALSO THE ACTUAL
WORKERS COMP COMPANIES
THEMSELVES WHO NOW ARE GOING TO
POLICE THEIR OWN.
CLIENTS FOR.
FOR FRAUD IN FOR ABUSES AND AND
GIVE A REMEDY FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORK WHO ARE INJURED ON THE JOB.
WHERE THERE'S IN THE GENERAL
INDUSTRY?
LIKE THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
SOME COMPLEX.
SUBCONTRACTING RELATIONSHIPS
UP THE CHAIN OF OF EMPLOYERS.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS THE.
I.
ASK ALL OF YOU TO TO VOTE I THIS
IS GOING TO BE VERY. USEFUL FROM
EMPLOYMENT FOR IT FROM A POINT
PROSECUTION PERSPECTIVE WHERE
THERE'S TO PLEASE WORKPLACE
ABUSES BUT ALSO TO EXPOSE THE
SEVERE EXPLOITATION THAT HAPPENS
IN THE DARKNESS IN THESE. LOW
WAGE JOBS IN THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ENOUGH
FLOOR AS AN ON THE LEGAL
DIRECTOR WITH THE MAINTENANCE
COOPERATION TRUST FUND FOR A
STATEWIDE JANITORIAL WATCHDOG
GROUP THAT WAS ORGANIZED BY A
RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYERS WHO ARE
OUTBID BY LAW BREAKING
COMPANIES.
AND OUR MISSION IS TO
SYSTEMATICALLY ELIMINATE UNFAIR
COMPETITION THE JUDGE OIL
INDUSTRY WE PARTNER WITH VARIOUS
STATE AGENCIES AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS OFFICES TO BRING ABOUT
COMPLAINTS IN THE INDUSTRY. AND
THIS WORK IS OFTEN COMPLICATED
BY CHARACTERISTICS FOUND IN THE
INFORMAL UNDERGROUND ECONOMY
SOME OF THOSE CHARACTERISTICS
ARE NOT HAVING ESTABLISH OFFICE
PLAYING SHALL GAINS WITH THE
LEGAL ENTITIES TO HIDE THEIR
TRUE IDENTITY HIDING ASSETS LACK
OF PAYROLL RECORDS CASH PAY. AND
MISS CLASSIFYING WORKERS OF THE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND THIS
GIVES EMPLOYERS IN THE
UNDERGROUND ECONOMY THE UPPER
HAND OVER LAW ABIDING
EMPLOYER'S.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX
PROVIDES JANITORS THE SAME
PROTECTION OF CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WERE MISS CLASSIFICATION
IS RAMPANT IN THIS IS NECESSARY
FOR THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY. AND
WITH CLASSIFICATION DOESN'T JUST
HURT BUSINESSES AND WORKERS BUT
IS ALSO HURTS THE STATE I MOST
OFTEN THE STATE LOSES OUT ON TAX
PREMIUMS. AND ALSO PAY THE BILL
FOR UNINSURED WORKERS THAT ARE
INJURED ON THE JOB.
FOR EXAMPLE IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
THE OWNER OF GOOD NEIGHBOR
SERVICES PLED GUILTY TO FELONY
TAX EVASION A WORKERS COMP
FRAUD.
JANET SMITH CLASSIFIED OVER A
HUNDRED JANITORIAL WORKERS.
AS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS TO
AVOID PAYING TAXES WORKERS COMP
PREMIUM FRAUD.
IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THIS FRAUD
IN THE CASE TOTALED SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. AND ALSO
WORKERS WERE LEFT WITH
BUT WITHOUT ANY COVERAGE FOR
WHEN THEY WERE INJURED ON THE
JOB.
AND THERE ARE MANY EMPLOYERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WITH THE
SAME PRACTICE AND SEE GETTING
CAUGHT AS JUST THE PRICE OF
DOING BUSINESS WE CONTINUE TO
PARTNER WITH AGENCIES ON THE
TYPES OF CASES. BUT WE STILL
HAVE NOT FIXED THE PROBLEM
EMPLOYERS WILL CONTINUE TO MISS
COST BY WORKERS AND THAT IS WHY
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX THE SO
CRITICAL TO THE JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY. WILL PUT THE ONUS ON
EMPLOYERS TO SHOW THAT
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS ARE
LEGITIMATE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS. AND THIS IS
NECESSARY IN AN INDUSTRY WHERE
MISS CLASSIFICATION IS RAMPANT
IT RESULTS IN WORKERS BEING
ROBBED OF BASIC WORKPLACE
PROTECTIONS LIKE MINIMUM WAGE
OVERTIME ANTI DISCRIMINATION AND
WORKERS COMPENSATION WHEN
THEY'RE INJURED.
MISS CLASSIFY WORKERS FACE A
REAL FEAR WHEN YOU ARE LOW WAGE
WORKER AND YOU LIVE PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK TO SUPPORT YOUR FAMILY.
FINAL WAGE CLAIM FOR BEING
MISCLASSIFIED MINT MEANS RISKING
YOUR JOB EXERCISING WORKPLACE
RIGHT TO SIMPLY NOT AN OPTION
FOR TOO MANY WORKERS AND THIS
ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO CONTINUE THE
PRACTICE OF MISS CLASSIFICATION
IN THE INDUSTRY.
WE NEED TO SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE
THAT IN THE JANITORIAL INDUSTRY
EMPLOYERS THAT BREAK THE LAW BY
MISCLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES WILL NOT
BE PROTECTED LAW ABIDING
COMPANIES NEED A FAIR
MARKETPLACE WERE FOLLOWING THE
LAW IS A FLOOR NOT THE FEELING.
AS IMPORTANTLY WORKERS NEED
THEIR RIGHTS TO BE RESPECTED
BOTH OF THESE ELEMENTS ARE
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO REGAIN A
LAWFUL ORDER IN THE INDUSTRY. AB
TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX WILL HELP
ACCOMPLISH THESE GOALS AND FOR
THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST ARRIVAL ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
EDUARDO SL YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MARY CHRIS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NICOLE MARQUEZ WITH WORK SAFE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BIRTH SILVER TAUPE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHICH HAVE COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
YOU
IS THERE ANYONE OUTSIDE THE DOOR
WHOSE.
WISHING THAT ON.
THAT WAS BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION
THAT I MISSED SOME WHO WANTED TO
ADD ON THE LAST BILL. PLEASE
ACCEPT MY APOLOGIES AND WE WILL
MAKE SURE TO GET YOU GOING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON.
LET THE RECORD REFLECT THEY WERE
HERE TO ADD ON.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
I SEE NONE RETURNED TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
THERE'S A MOTION.
I'LL SECOND THERE IS A SECOND
MOTION AND A SECOND.
I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THAT'S WHEN I ABOUT.
BUT HOW THIS BILL HAS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
JUDICIARY THURMAN AYE AYE
THURMAN AYE FLORA GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I.
THE BILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS.
AND THE REMAINING BILL AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY TWO.
MY EASY WEEK.
BRINGING THE FIRE NEXT WEEK.
HEY.
WARNING OF.
I DO NOT TRACING. HAY CON.
IRATE.
AND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN A SAN DIEGO BASED
COUPLE WAS ARRESTED FOR
ENSLAVING AN INDONESIAN DOMESTIC
WORKER IN THEIR HOME. FORCING
HER TO WORK BETWEEN FIFTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN HOURS A DAY WITHNO PAY
AND NO DAYS OFF.
THE VIEWS THE VICTIM MENTALLY
AND PHYSICALLY BY RETAINING HER
PASSPORT MAKING HER BELIEVE THAT
SHE WOULD BE PHYSICALLY HARMED
IF YOU DO NOT PERFORM HER
DUTIES.
IN ANOTHER RECENT CASE IN ORANGE
COUNTY A WOMAN WAS ARRESTED FOR
KEEPING FIVE WOMEN ONE FROM
KENYA AND FOR FROM THE
PHILIPPINES AS SLAVES FOR HER
FAMILY.
TWENTY FOURTEEN URBAN INSTITUTE
STUDY THAT MANY VICTIMS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING WERE SUBJECT TO A
VARIETY OF PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL STE CALLED
TACTICS.
TO CONTROL IMMENSELY VICTIMS
INCLUDING THE USE OF DOCUMENT
SERVITUDE.
DOCUMENT SERVITUDE IS A PRACTICE
OF AN EMPLOYER WITHHOLDING AND
IMMIGRANTS LEGAL DOCUMENTS FOR
PURPOSES OF AND MANIPULATING THE
EMPLOYEE.
WITH THE VAST MAJORITY OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING VICTIMS BEEN
IMMIGRANTS IT IS VITAL THAT THE
CALIFORNIA PROTECT THESE WORKERS
BY PREVENTING UNSCRUPULOUS
EMPLOYERS FROM TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO HELPS
PROTECT WORKERS AGAINST THE
MORAL. OR IMMORAL PRACTICE OF
DOCUMENT SERVITUDE BY FIRST
PROVIDING A FRAMEWORK TO HOLD
THE PLAYERS ACCOUNTABLE WHO
ENGAGE IN DOCUMENT SERVITUDE AND
DETERMINING A VIOLATION AS A
MISDEMEANOR AND POTENTIAL OF UP
TO TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS CIVIL
PENALTY. IT ALSO ESTABLISHES A
WORKERS BILL OF RIGHTS IN WHICH
THE EMPLOYER MUST PROVIDE A COPY
TO EVERY WORKER.
AS OUTLINED A PAGE TO THE NOW
SINCE I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO FURTHER CLARIFY
EXACTLY WHICH EMPLOYERS WOULD BE
SUBJECT TO THIS BILL. BECAUSE
UNLIKE MOST THE BILLS WE DO THIS
IS A PROBLEM AND SMALLER
EMPLOYMENT SITUATIONS NOT WITH
LARGE COMPANIES. WITH ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY TWO IS MARY ARAB AL AND
BEAR IT WITH THIS ANY OF COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
THURMOND AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AS.
SHE SAID I'M VERY OWN VERTAMAE
DE PDA FROM THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO.
OF THE CBO COUNTY DA SUMMER
STEPHAN IS THE SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND I'M HERE ON HER BEHALF.
I AM THE TEAM LEADER IN OUR
OFFICE FOR.
HUMAN TRAFFICKING I'M A SOUND
TO THE SAN DIEGO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING TASK FORCE AND I'M
CURRENTLY THE CHAIR OF THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL OF SAN DIEGO ON
HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND CRUCIAL SEXUAL EXPLOITATION
OF CHILDREN.
IN MY TIME WITH HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES I'VE SEEN THAT
THESE VICTIMS OFTEN HIDE IN THE
SHADOWS THEY LIVE IN THE
SHADOWS.
I TOO HAVE SEEN TRAFFICKERS WHO
WITHHOLD DOCUMENTS ALLOW THEM TO
EXPIRE AND THEN HOLD IMMIGRATION
STATUS OVER THE HEADS OF THEIR
VICTIMS.
IN SPEAKING WITH SURVIVORS AND
VICTIMS ESPECIALLY IMMIGRANTS I
HAVE FOUND THAT THEY OFTEN DO
NOT KNOW OUR SYSTEM.
OUR LAWS HOW WE ENFORCE OUR LAWS
WHAT THEIR RIGHTS ARE OR EVEN
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE FOR THEM
RIGHTS.
PA AS NOT NEED OF CITIZENS.
THEY ARE OFTEN THEN MANIPULATED
FIVE TRAFFICKER WHO EXPLAINS OUR
SYSTEM TO THEM FOR HIS OR HER
ADVANTAGE.
FOR EXAMPLE THE TRAFFICKER SAYS.
THAT HE OR SHE NEEDS TO KEEP
THE DOCUMENTS FOR SAFE KEEPING
AND THEN INFORMS THE VICTIM YOU
CANNOT GO OUTSIDE INTO PUBLIC
WITHOUT YOUR DOCUMENTS.
WE KNOW THAT'S FALSE THE VICTIMS
DO NOT.
IN ANOTHER ONE THE THREAT WAS
YEAH HE'LL BE DEPORTED.
BUT YOUR CHILDREN STAY IN THE
UNITED STATES THE GOVERNMENT
WILL KEEP YOUR CHILDREN HERE. IF
YOU DON'T GO ALONG WITH WHAT I
DO. THIS ALLOWS THE TRAFFICKER
TO FURTHER ISOLATE CONTROL THE
VICTIMS.
WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE JUST
ICING.
IN THAT SEVENTY ONE PERCENT OF
THE VICTIMS OF COME IN UNLAWFUL
VISAS.
AND THE BY THE TIME THEY ESCAPE
SIXTY NINE PERCENT ARE NO LONGER
AUTHORIZED.
THIS BILL WILL SHINE A LIGHT FOR
ALL WORKERS ON THE LIES OF
TRAFFICKERS THAT WILL PROVIDE A
TOOL TO EDUCATE OUR WORKERS
ABOUT THEIR RIGHTS AND TO
PROTECT THEM AGAINST THOSE
EMPLOYERS. WHO WOULD TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THEM?
IT'S ALSO A TOOL TO HOLD THOSE
OFFENDING EMPLOYERS ACCOUNTABLE
TO HELP STOP THIS CRIME.
AND AGAIN CBO COUNTY DA SUMMER
STEP IN IS THE SPONSOR THIS BILL
AND WE ARE JUST SUPPORT AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
MARY CHRIS OF THE CALIFORNIA MY
GRANDPA'S HE CENTER IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU.
NICHOLAS CHAVEZ ON BEHALF THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
Q..
RENEE PARAMYTHIA YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
LIQUID NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS AND SUPPORT THE
QUEUE.
NICOLE MARQUEZ WORK SAFE IN
SUPPORT. YOU.
RUTH SILVER TOLD THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHICH HAVE COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
ACTUALLY AT ON IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL TURN TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS.
I'LL SECOND.
MISS MELENDEZ TO DO YOU WANT TO.
COME.
THIS MELENDEZ LIKE SECOND.
BILL'S BEEN MOVE I CINEMA KALRA
SECONDED BY SOME REMEMBER
MELENDEZ.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE HAVERSACK
CLASS WHEN I HAVE THIS BILL HAS
AN AYE RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE THURMAN. AYE THURMAN
AYE FLORA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE CONSULTS
WHICH I JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ. MELINDA'S I.
HILL IS OUT CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR THREE BILLS.
.
I RECOGNIZE SOME MEMBER BONTA AS
PRESIDENT WE.
READY FOR HIM TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY SIX.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE.
SIXTY SIX TODAY IN IT ANNA.
TIME IN WHICH THE MEAT TO
MOVEMENT HAS TAKEN CENTER STAGE
IT'S BECOME CLEAR THAT WE MUST
DO MORE.
PROTECT SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN THE WORKPLACE.
CALIFORNIA.
NEEDS TO SET THE BAR HIGHER AND
CANNED EXTENDING EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTIONS TO SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE IS A COMMON SENSE MUCH
NEEDED NEXT STEP TO ENSURING. A
SAFE ENVIRONMENT.
FOR ALL AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
SIX WOULD GIVE SURVIVORS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS JOB PROTECTED LEAVE
ALREADY AVAILABLE FOR SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT. OR STOCKING
ADDITIONALLY THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW FAMILY MEMBERS TO ACCESS
THE SAME PROTECTIONS IF A LOVED
ONE HAS EXPERIENCED SEXUAL
ASSAULT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
STALKING. AND OR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SO THAT THEY CAN HELP
THEIR FAMILY MEMBER TO ACCESS
CRITICAL. SERVICES THIS IS
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT FOR
SURVIVORS WHO ARE MINORS AND MAY
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO
TRANSPORTATION OR WHO NEED
SUPPORT. GOING TO A COURT
HEARING.
TO BE CLEAR THIS BILL DOES NOT
CREATE ADDITIONAL PAID TIME OFF
BUT SIMPLY SAYS THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SURVIVORS AND
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBERS CAN
CLAIM PAID TIME OFF.
I ALREADY OFFERED TO THEM BY THE
EMPLOYER OR TAKE UNPAID TIME.
DEAL WITH THE TRAUMA THEY HAVE
ENTERED.
THERE OUR EMPLOYER SAFEGUARD
VERIFICATIONS IN THIS BILL AND
WHICH A SURVIVOR AND THEIR
IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER MUST
PROVIDE PROOF.
OF THEIR ABSENCE SUCH AS A
POLICE REPORT AYE DOCTORS ARE
COUNSELORS NOTE A COURT ORDER OR
COURT DOCUMENT.
WE'VE HEARD THE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THIS COMMITTEE AND WILL WORK
WITH THE NEXT COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY COMMITTEE TO
AMEND THE BILL TO DEAL WITH AT
THE COMMITTEE'S CONCERNS RAISED
HERE AND.
IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIANS LEAD
THE WAY FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
SURVIVORS AND THEIR LOVED ONES
TO ENSURE THEY ARE SUPPORTED. IN
THEIR TIME OF NEED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY
THREE SIX.
THANK YOU READY FOR YOUR FIRST
WITNESS.
YES I HAVE. WITNESSES YA JULIA
PARISH STAFF ATTORNEY WITH LEGAL
AID AT WORK AND CHRISTINE SMITH
PUBLIC POLICY COORDINATOR
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO AND.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
CHAIRMAN THURMOND AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HEARING MY TESTIMONY TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
SIX.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE MATH BUT
THE CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIPS AND
INVESTED VIOLENCE SUPPORTER OF
THIS IMPORTANT BILL.
THE PARTNERSHIP IS A STATEWIDE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COALITION
REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS SERVING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS THEIR
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
WOMEN'S HEALTH SURVEY
APPROXIMATELY FORTY PERCENT OF
CALIFORNIA WOMEN EXPERIENCE
PHYSICAL INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE IN THEIR LIFETIMES.
A STUDY DONE BY LEGAL AID AT
WORK FOUND THAT NEARLY FORTY
PERCENT OF SURVIVORS IN
CALIFORNIA REPORTED EITHER BEING
FIRED OR FEAR TERMINATION DUE
TO.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
THE PREVALENCE OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SEXUAL ASSAULT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND STALKING IN THE
UNITED STATES AND SPECIFICALLY
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE OF HARMFUL
EFFECT ON THE ABILITY OF
SURVIVORS TO MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT
AND FAMILIES TO MAINTAIN
ECONOMIC STABILITY.
A SURVIVOR FROM THE BAY AREA
ASKED ME TO SHARE HER STORY WITH
YOU.
AT THE AGE OF NINETEEN SHOES
PHYSICALLY ABUSED
STOPPED AND HARASSED BY HER EX
PARTNER.
HERE TO HEAR HER WORKPLACE AND
HARASS OUR FRIENDS.
HER THERAPIST RECOMMENDED A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER BUT IT WAS THE FIRST TIME
SHE HER SIBLINGS AND HER FRIENDS
HAD EVEN HEARD OF RESTRAINING
ORDER.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT THEY
LEARN ABOUT IN SCHOOL OR EVEN
FROM HEIR PARENTS BUT THOUGH
HER SIBLINGS WERE UNSURE OF HOW
TO HELP. THEY'RE WILLING TO
OFFER ANY SUPPORT SHE NEEDED.
RESTRAINING ORDER FORM WAS
TRAUMATIZED THEME SHOULD NEVER
BEEN IN COURT BEFORE AND
COMBINED BE SEEN HER EXIT NEEDS
ARE GONE SHOES FILLED WITH FEAR
AND ANXIETY.
ON THAT DAY THOUGH PERSON LEANS
ATTENDED COURT WITH HER.
BECAUSE OF THEIR PHYSICAL
PRESENCE SHE DIDN'T FEEL ALONE
AND SHE FELL IN POWER TO SPEAK
BEFORE THE JUDGE.
THE JUDGE GRANTED HER THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER AND SHE BELIEVES THAT THIS
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN POSSIBLE
WITHOUT HER SIBLINGS EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT.
HOWEVER FOR MANY SURVIVORS WHO
BENEFIT FROM THE SUPPORT OF A
FAMILY MEMBER ATTENDING CORPS OR
OTHER APPOINTMENTS WITH THEM.
THOSE SEEMLY MEMBERS ARE
CURRENTLY UNABLE TO TAKE TIME
OFF OF WORK AND BASS BARRIERS TO
SUPPORTING THE SURVIVORS THAT
THEY CARE ABOUT.
POP SCENE AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
SIX WORLD OPTIMALLY MEMBERS
ACCESS JOB PROTECTION BELIEVE
AND ACCOMMODATIONS TO PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS.
SEEKING RELIEF PERTAINING%
SERVICES AND COUNSELING WHERE
CROSS LEADER WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE
THING KILL AND.
MY NAME IS JULIE PARRISH M.
INTERNET LEGALLY THAT WORK WHICH
IS A STATEWIDE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF LOW WAGE WORKERS AND
THINK YOU AND.
SO IN OUR BONTA AND ON THAT
COMMITTEE FOR HEARING THIS BILL
TODAY.
I THINK ONE OF THE MAIN GOALS
AND PURPOSES THAT THIS BILL CAN
ACCOMPLISH IS TO HELP BREAK THE
SILENCE THAT WE SEE. AMONG
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT THERE'S A SIMILAR SORT
OF STIGMA AND DIFFICULTY FOR
PEOPLE TO COME FORWARD AND SEEK
AND ACCESS THE SERVICES WE NEED
AND WE NEED TO JUST MAKE THAT AS
EASY FOR THEM AS POSSIBLE
WITHOUT FEARING. OTHER SORTS OF
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES.
LIKE LOSING YOUR JOB OR. AND YOU
KNOW NOT BEING ABLE TO HAVE YOUR
SISTER COME WITH YOU AN
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT MOMENT IN
YOUR LIFE AND THE PURPOSE OF
THIS BILL REALLY HARMONIZES BOTH
THE PROTECTIONS.
TO ALLOW THE SURVIVOR TO HAVE
SOMETIME OFF TO SEEK SERVICES
AND GET THAT SUPPORT AND THAT
HERE SHE MIGHT NEED. ANTI ONE
EXAMPLE FROM OUR HELP PLANE
RECENTLY WAS FROM A WORKING
WOMAN WHO WORKED IN A RESTAURANT
WHO IS AND SEXUALLY HARASSED BY
A CO WORKER. AND YOU COMPLAIN TO
HER EMPLOYER. AND THE EMPLOYER
SORT OF INSTRUCTED THE COR GOING
TO DO IT ANYMORE BUT SHE STILL
HAD TO WORK IN SORT OF A VERY
SMALL PHYSICAL SPACE WITH HIM
AND SHE REALLY NEEDED. TIME AWAY
ON A TIME AWAY FROM THAT
SITUATION AND THERE WASN'T.
LIKE AN EASIER APPROPRIATE
REMEDY IN EXISTING LAW THAT SHE
COULD USE TO HELP HER GET THAT
BECAUSE THE EMPLOYER HAD SORT OF
STOPS THE HARASSMENT FROM
HAPPENING IN CONTINUING WHICH
WAS IMPORTANT. BUT IT WASN'T THE
FULL.
I'M RECOVERY THAT SHE NEED AND
SHE NEEDED MORE THAN THAT.
INTO THIS BILL WOULD REALLY
HELP.
PEOPLE IN THAT SITUATION ACCESS
MORE OF WHAT THEY NEED TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE WORKING AND AND
BE ABLE TO BREAK THE SILENCE
AROUND THESE CRITICAL ISSUES.
WE WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO ADD
ON IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WEREN'T
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU.
THE LARGEST RENT POOREST WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
Q..
SORRY MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
CHRISTY. BE OF THE CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS OF CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANGELIQUE WITH ANY SW IN
SUPPORT.
Q..
NICOLE MARQUEZ WORK SAFE IN
SUPPORT.
RUTH SOBRE TAUPE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHICH THEY'VE COALITION
IN SUPPORT THEY Q. ANYONE ELSE
ADDING ON IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON LARA CURTIS
WITH CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE FIRST ONE I
THINK THEY AUTHORS OFFICE
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN WILLING
TO I MEET WITH US AND TAKE TIME
TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE. AT LENGTH
AND THERE ARE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE A WITHIN
THAT THE.
BILL A WE HAVE DISCUSSED
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE NOT WE'VE YET
TO SEE AN AMENDMENTS ALL DISCUSS
GENERALLY OUR CONCERNS AS THE
BILL STANDS TODAY.
FIRST OF ALL THE EXPERTS AT THE
ADDITIONAL FAMILY LEAVE IS A
CONCERN FOR US JUST BECAUSE ONCE
THAT LEAVE IS TAKEN IT'S
PROTECTED AND THEN ANY
RAMIFICATION BY ANY ACTION THE
EMPLOYER TAKES AFTER THAT WOULD
THEN BE TIED TO THAT LEAVING
COULD THEN BE IMPLICATED AS.
TAKING M. AS I AM RETALIATING
AGAINST AN INDIVIDUAL FOR TAKING
THAT WE SO THAT'S OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE FAMILY MEMBER LEAVE.
ARE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL AS
DRAFTED NOW IS THERE ISN'T THE
PROTECTIONS AROUND THESE.
AROUND FOR THE EMPLOYER AROUND
THESE TYPES OF LEAVE THAT THERE
ARE FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT DOES REQUIRE A POLICE
REPORT OR AND SOME SORT OF
CERTIFICATION FROM A MEDICAL
PROVIDER. AND THAT'S LACKING IN
THE CURRENT LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
SEWN INDIVIDUAL COULD ASSERT
THAT THEY WERE TAKING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT LEAVE FOR A SIMPLE
GLANCE AND FOR SOMEONE
ACCIDENTALLY BRUSHING UP AGAINST
THEM IN AN ELEVATOR. I'M BECAUSE
THERE'S NO FOR SEXUAL HARASSMENT
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT THE THE
SCOPE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS
EXTREMELY BROAD AND NOT ALL
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WHILE IT'S ALL
USUALLY INAPPROPRIATE NOT ALL
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IS ACTUALLY
ACTIONABLE UNDER THE LAW. AND SO
WITHOUT SOME SORT OF
NOTIFICATION OR VERIFICATION FOR
THE EMPLOYER AND THIS IS A GOOD
THIS COULD BE ABUSED AND THAT'S
WHERE OUR CONCERN LIES THAT WE
WOULD LIKE SOME VERIFICATION.
ADDITIONALLY.
THERE IS.
THE LANGUAGE IS IN THE LABOR
CODE AND FEE HA ACTUALLY.
CONTROL SEXUAL HARASSMENT
RETALIATION DISCRIMINATION IT'S
OUR CONCERNS ARE THERE THAT IT'S
WE HAVE DISCUSSED WITH THE
AUTHOR. AND LET ME JUST NOTE IT.
FOR EXAMPLE IN SECTION ONE OF
THE BILL. LABOR CODE TO THIRTY.
IN SUBDIVISION DE ONE THE
EMPLOYER THE EMPLOYER SHALL GIVE
THE EMPLOYER REASONABLE ADVANCE
NOTICE OF INTENTION TO TAKE OFF.
IN DE TO THEN IT SAYS
CERTIFICATION SHALL BE
SUFFICIENT IN ANY OF THE
FOLLOWING FORMS.
A TWO A. B. AND SEE THE PROBLEM
IS IS THAT.
THAT NONE OF THESE INCLUDE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ONLY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR STOCKING.
SO THERE IS NO NOTICE REQUIRED
ON THE SEXUAL HARASSMENT ASPECT
TO THE EMPLOYER SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
RECTIFIED AND AGAIN. IN THE
ANALYSIS I THINK POINTS OUT A
NUMBER OF ISSUES AND WILL
CONTINUE TALKING WITH THE AUTHOR
ABOUT. SOME THESE LANGUAGE
CHANGES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WISHING TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION.
THE CALL RICE CALIFORNIA FACTORS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE
ARE OPPOSED FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON KIDDIE HANSON
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED FOR THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER OPPOSITION.
SCENE NONE WILL TURN TO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
TURNED TO THE AUTHOR IT DID YOU
WANT HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE.
CONCERNS RAISED BY OPPOSITION.
YES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FIRST OFF THANK YOU
TO TELL YOUR STAFF AND AND AND
COMMITTEE FOR. THE DIFFERENT
SUGGESTIONS FOR HOW TO
STRENGTHEN THE BILL GOING FOUR
TO ONE TO ADDRESS A COUPLE OF
THOSE. ON THE SPECIFIC ISSUE
AROUND NOTICE IN AND
VERIFICATION ITS AND SAFEGUARDS
FOR THE EMPLOYER WE HAVE ALWAYS
HAD EVERY INTENTION THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WOULD REQUIRE. WOULD
REQUIRE THE SAME VERIFICATIONS
AS SEXUAL ASSAULT AND STALKING
AND DOMESTIC VIOLENCE WE THINK
WAS A DRAFTING ERROR THAT IT NOT
BE INCLUDED WE ARE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO COMMIT NOW THAT THEY
ALL HAVE THE EXACT SAME.
REQUIREMENTS FOR NOTICE AND
VERIFICATION SO.
IT WAS I'LL ALWAYS OUR
ATTENTION THAT WOULD NEED TO
WEAR USE THAT CANCERS NOTRE
DOCTOR'S NOTE OR POLICE REPORTER
COURT DOCUMENT. THAT TO SUPPORT.
YOUR.
YOU EAT TO JUSTIFY BEING ABSENT
SO I WE WILL FIX THAT IN THE
NEXT COMMITTEE AND COMMIT TO
THAT NOW THAT WAS NEVER INTENDED
TO BE THE CASE IN THIS BILL. OUT
WE ALSO ARE WE ARE VERY
RESPECTFUL OF IN AND
THAT WOULD FROM THE COMMITTEE
THAT WOULD INCLUDE EXPANDING THE
DEFINITION TO INCLUDE OTHER
TYPES OF REST INCLUDING RACIAL
AND DISABILITY IN AGE NATIONAL
ORIGIN. NATIONAL ORIGIN
RELIGION.
WHERE I AM VERY INTERESTED IN
EXPLORING THAT EXPANSION AND AND
APPRECIATE THE?
SUGGESTION BY THE COMMITTEE.
SO I I THINK THAT HELPS ADDRESS
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE
WE'VE HAD CONSTRUCTIVE
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION IN WHICH WERE
BOTH LISTENING TO EACH OTHER AND
I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO GET CLOSER.
CONCERNS AS WE GO FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I ASSUME NINE.
TURNING TO THE COMMITTEE OF THE
COMMITTEE'S PLEASURE IS OUR
MOTION.
THERE WAS A MOTION I'LL SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE ANY ADDITIONAL
CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THIS BILL HAS AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO JUDICIARY
THURMAN AYE AYE THURMAN AYE
FLORA. GONZALEZ FLETCHER
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE JONES
SAWYER. KALRA. MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING.
BUT BILLS ON CALL NEEDS ONE MORE
VOTE WILL BE LEAVE IN THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS SO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF THANK
YOU.
BUT THIS IS OUR FINAL BILL FOR
THE DAY WILL BELIEVE IN THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
WHO WISH TO ADD ON THAT WE CAN
DO?
ADD ONS FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE
PRESENT NOW.
.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA JONES SAWYER
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA. JONES
SAWYER MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT FORTY ONE ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE.
AB TWENTY NINE FORTY SIX.
ABSENT MEMBERS MCCARTY.
MCCARTY BY.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER. GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE.
WE'LL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR A
FEW MORE MOMENTS REMEMBERS WHO
STILL NEED THAT ON.
BY.
NOT THAT.
YEAH AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY SIX
ABSENT MEMBER FLORA JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX ABSENT
MEMBER JONES SAWYER. AND SWEAR
I.
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
JONES SAWYER. JONES SAWYER AYE
HE'S.
CHECKING.
I'M TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY TWO
FLORA AYE.
WHEN.
AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY FOUR
ABSENT MEMBER FLORA.
FLORA I.
MAKING.
THAT SEEKS.
IT'S ME AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
SIX ABSENT MEMBER FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING.
KALRA ON AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY
SIX.
KALRA AYE.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY SIX ABSENT
MEMBER FLORA.
FLORA I.
THIS COMPLETES OUR HEARINGS
WHERE JOHN THANK YOU.
DOT.
YOU.
ABSOLUTELY